en este vídeo vamos a ver cómo teniendo
una determinada recta de regresión y
unos puntos que nos marcan un
determinado error
vamos a ver Cómo calcular
un valor que va a ser el de coeficiente
de determinación para esta recta
Entonces si tenemos esta recta Y estos
puntos y si queremos averiguar el valor
medio de y
vamos a tener que sumar todos los
valores de y es decir menos 3 menos 1
más 2 más 3 y a todo esto dividirlo por
de esto vamos a obtener que este se
puede simplificar con este menos uno más
dos es uno es decir que nos queda un
cuarto o 0,25
que puede que no llegue a ser de mayor
utilidad
ahora bien Si nosotros queremos calcular
el coeficiente de regresión vamos a
tener que hacer ciertos cálculos
cálculos que van a ser muy tediosos para
eso vamos a utilizar
una hoja de cálculo la tengo acá
preparada con los valores para x para
ahí Es decir completar todos los puntos
de x y de y vamos a tener esta y
estrella que va a ser la función con los
valores de reemplazados de x y Tenemos
también el error cuadrado de la recta de
regresión y el error cuadrado de la
media de y por lo tanto si reemplazamos
los valores por los puntos que tenemos
vamos a tener menos dos
menos 1
vamos a tener uno y vamos a tener cuatro
en el X de cada uno de los puntos en el
y vamos a tener menos 3 vamos a tener
menos 1 vamos a tener dos y vamos a
tener tres y ahora sí en la en esta y
estrella como dijimos vamos a tener la
función con los valores de X es decir
que vamos a tener
los valores de la función tenemos que la
función es igual a y
41 sobre 42
x menos 5 sobre 2 sobre 21 Perdón no
sobre 12
y en estas x vamos a reemplazar por los
puntos que tenemos les recuerdo que los
puntos que tenemos son menos dos menos
tres menos uno menos uno
uno dos y cuatro tres
Entonces vamos a reemplazar por cada uno
de estos valores para eso vamos a hacer
que cada una de las celdas es igual
a
41 dividido 42
por el valor de X en este caso la celda
2 todo esto menos
5 sobre 21
esto nos da un valor de
-2,19048 extendemos esta misma fórmula a
todas las celdas y vamos a tener que
parar el punto 11 el valor de la de y
estrella Es decir de y con el valor de X
es
-1,21429 para el punto 12 es
0,7381 y para el punto 4 3 es 3,6
periódico prácticamente
en el error cuadrado de la recta lo que
vamos a hacer es justamente calcular ese
error cuadrado es decir vamos a calcular
el valor que tenemos en y
menos el que tenemos
en y estrella decir el valor de la recta
todo esto elevado al cuadrado es decir
estamos calculando el error cuadrado de
la recta
reemplazando todos los valores tenemos
ese bendito error que tanto buscamos de
cuánto es extendemos esto todas las
celdas Y tenemos el error
correspondiente a cada uno de los datos
y ahora si queremos calcular el error
cuadrado pero de la media de y lo que
vamos a tener que hacer es
ahí al valor de y
restarle el valor medio de y que era
0,25
y está también lo vamos a tener que
Elevar al cuadrado por lo tanto nos
queda
10,5625 extendemos esto todas las celdas
y obtenemos este valor
Entonces ahora tenemos el error de la
recta para cada uno de los puntos pero
si queremos averiguar el error total de
la recta es decir el error para
averiguar la variación total vamos a
tener que sumar todos los errores
correspondientes a cada uno de los
puntos Es decir para el punto menos dos
menos tres el error es de 0,65
etcétera para el punto menos uno menos
uno el error es
0,04592 para el punto 12 el error es de
1,5924 y para el punto 4 3 el error de
la recta de regresión es de 0,4
periódico insisto como nosotros nos
interesa el calcular el error total
vamos a tener que hacer una sumatoria de
todos estos valores
es decir una suma de todos estos valores
Y eso nos da
2,7381 aproximadamente vamos a copiarlo
acá vamos a borrar esto
vamos a poner que el error cuadrado de
la recta
Es aproximadamente 2,74
Y si queremos ahora averiguar el error
total de la de la y media de la medias
de y tenemos que hacer la suma pero de
la columna de la error cuadrado de y
esto Entonces es igual a la suma de
todos estos valores
y nos da que es
22,75 vamos a notar Entonces el error
cuadrado de la media de y es igual a
22,75
ahora queremos averiguar
el coeficiente de determinación
coeficiente
de determinación
determinación
vamos a tener que hacer
ese de la recta el error cuadrado de la
recta dividido el error cuadrado de la
media de y por lo tanto
si recurrimos por última vez a nuestra
hoja de cálculos vamos a tener que hacer
que esto
dividido este valor y nos da
0,12036 es decir aproximadamente
0,12
0,12 que nos entrega un porcentaje del
12% Pero qué es este 12% Bueno Este 12%
es el porcentaje de la variación Total
no mostrada no mostrada
por la variación de x o por la recta de
regresión pero nosotros nos interesa
conocer el porcentaje
de la variación total sí mostrada es
decir si el coeficiente de determinación
definitivamente tenemos que buscarlo que
nos valemos de esto que es igual a uno
menos
s de la recta el error cuadrado de la
recta sobre el error cuadrado de la
media de y que esto es igual a 0,12 como
lo averiguamos
por lo tanto si hacemos uno menos 0,12
obtenemos que
0,88 es decir un 88 por ciento es el
porcentaje de la variación Total que sí
está mostrada por la variación de X
entonces
nuestro coeficiente de determinación
nuestro r al cuadrado es igual a 0,88